[Music]
with covet cases
on the rise in many countries the race
to find an effective vaccine
is becoming a more pressing concern
every day
the pharmaceutical company pfizer has
just announced that
they have successfully produced a covet
19 vaccine in the lab
which is 95 effective against the virus
could this be the solution to the
pandemic and
where do i sign up how long will it take
for a vaccine to be readily available
worldwide
what makes the pfizerkovit vaccine
so unique and who gets
access to it first can i call dibs on it
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a coveted vaccine were available
tomorrow
[Music]
with over a million deaths and counting
covet 19 has hit hard
in order to stop it in its tracks we'll
need vaccines to be distributed
worldwide but how can we determine which
countries get the vaccine first
would the richest nations get access
before the poorest ones
with lockdowns stifling many countries
economies
could everyone afford it some of the
richer countries like the uk
have signed expensive agreements with
six potential coronavirus vaccines
this has sparked controversy as hogging
a vaccine before it's made
could leave vulnerable countries behind
luckily
the who or world health organization has
created the kovacs plan
to level the playing field its aim is to
raise two billion dollars by the year
2021
to help buy and fairly distribute a
vaccine
worldwide many countries are pooling
their resources together
and they hope to guarantee 92 lower
income countries in
africa asia and latin america fast
and fair access to the vaccine
if this kovacs plan works all the
countries involved will receive enough
doses to vaccinate
20 percent of their population starting
with the most
vulnerable people first this would
include
health care workers the elderly in
nursing homes and their caretakers
as well as people with medical
conditions putting them at risk
then people over 65 would be next in
line
and finally people under the age of 50
will get it last these vaccinations will
be distributed to
convenient locations like schools
pharmacies and
even train stations while we won't know
for sure
how bad the pandemic will get before the
vaccine is readily available
researchers suggest that the death count
could reach
two and a half million by january
but if we step up our axe wear masks and
keep our distance this number could be a
lot smaller
so how exactly will this vaccine get
approved
well first it must go through rigorous
testing to ensure that it's safe
this can be a long and expensive process
and
normally only about 10 percent of
vaccine trials
are successful before a vaccine can be
tested
it has to first undergo screenings and
evaluations to determine
which antigens should be used antigens
are like the secret weapons of the
vaccine they
contain a small amount of the disease or
virus-causing organism
to trigger an immune response in this
pre-clinical phase antigens are tested
on
animals which share similar genetic
makeups to us
if all goes well scientists will then
start
phase one where a small group of human
volunteers are given the vaccine
researchers and doctors will monitor if
the right immune response is triggered
and figure out the correct dosage for
humans
in phase 2 the vaccine is given to
several hundred volunteers
of varying age groups and finally in
phase
3 thousands of volunteers will be tested
these tests will be conducted across
multiple countries to assure the results
of the vaccine
applied to many different populations
after all is said and done
each country will review the study data
and decide whether to authorize the
vaccine for use
once it's made public the vaccine will
need to be constantly monitored to
ensure
it works as it should so
what's so special about this pfizer
vaccine
and when can we get it well
the pfizer vaccine is currently in phase
three of testing meaning it's being
tested worldwide
companies are waiting for more data to
come in before they begin manufacturing
unlike traditional vaccines the pfizer
vaccine
uses a novel genetic technology that is
on the forefront of science
using synthetic mrna the immune system
is activated and fights the virus mrna
vaccines are unique
and have never been licensed for an
infectious disease
traditionally vaccines inject small
doses of the disease-causing organism
but
mrna vaccines trick the body into
producing some of the viral proteins
itself
think of it as a tiny cellular magician
instead of rabbits he's pulling
coronaviruses out of its hat
abra corona so far the vaccine has been
tested on 43
500 people with only mild side effects
it will require two doses three weeks
apart
pfizer has reported that up to 50
million doses could be available
globally
by the end of the year and they expect
to have
1.3 billion doses ready in 2021
while all this sounds hopeful one of the
challenges
will be distributing it the vaccine must
be kept at
minus 70 degrees or below in order to
last
six months this can eat up a lot of
energy and money and can be a challenge
for top
hospitals let alone rural communities
hopefully the kovacs plan will cover the
costs
even if the vaccine is ready to go it
will not be a quick fix and
will likely take years before everyone
is vaccinated
well i hope it doesn't take more than
two years
well guess what that's a story
for another what if